yeah welcome to a new five-minute game
better make a move what be behind in
time so early so Lou Lopez me and f5
yeah f5 yeah played this myself a couple
of times the slimmin or Janusz gambit
but I must admit that I'm mostly forgot
the theory yeah this is quite a good
line with my D form yeah I had looked at
this from a black perspective of course
should I play c3 probably
let's retreat the bishop so that he
cannot so easily Castle you know blacks
plan has to go Queen e7 Bishop e6
so if he takes I can still recapture
with the Queen preventing Kesling let's
first try to arrest this Bishop a bit
mmm you know I forgot to really forgot
how this is this is played let's grab a
tempo under on the bishop hmm
I thought that no not going to d5 would
irritate black but maybe he can just
guess along but I have before him I have
performed before b5 attacking this pawn
okay so he won't castle long this this
much is clear question is I mean what
has happening he will be him probably
will play Queen to to f7
hmm Brooke do you want Queen f7 oh it's
um it's really nothing
yeah it's difficult I only know this as
mentioned from from a black perspective
and this doesn't make it easy hmm yeah
should I yeah probably
this is a slight displacement of the
king and now it's it's really annoying
that he's got this pressure on f2 let's
try to play f3 in some way
yeah Aveda 3 so it's not exactly great
for white and I'm not in trouble but I'm
not sure if this is good I'm on the H
file it's probably equal all this aha so
it's trying to to do something maybe
based on the fact that I cannot oppose
on the G foul possible yeah but still I
don't think there's much going on
I can play this come on let's let's
let's just make a draw here you would
probably take now otherwise I go no g4
or something and then I continue and
root G 2 root D - yeah it's just it's
just Josh
very Jewish or maybe yeah that's not
nothing happening at all
you know I can easily defend F 3 and C 3
and he's a bit more compact here with
the spawns but it's a it's a drawn yeah
it was a bit bit of a shame this opening
but I'm I don't really know how to play
for an advantage against this so it was
a bit bit difficult to play against your
your own your own openings
yeah for draw maybe he wants to play on
time no yeah well they could have played
on I'm but it's it's not really
happening much yeah this was a really
lame game sorry for that but sometimes
just some you you don't get get get
anything in the opening the Schliemann
is a good line against the rule no pass
maybe here's something else I don't know
a bishop g5 I know that this is pretty
much okay for black played that myself
quite a number of times you get we've
got good pieces is black in a good
structure so no big problems yeah thanks
for watching this anyway